well good afternoon I'm Stephen dar
Wallaby Yale philosophy department and
the Terry lecture committee and it's my
great pleasure and honor to introduce
Kwame Anthony Eppie epiha to deliver the
third in his Terry lectures if you've
been attending these fascinating
lectures you know that Professor Apia
has titled his lectures the anatomy of
religion today's lecture is titled
religion after Darwin Anthony Appiah has
made a staggering intellectual
contribution to a stunning variety of
fields his philosophical training at
Cambridge was primarily in the
analytical philosophies of language and
mind receiving the PhD in philosophy at
Cambridge in 1982 he came to Yale as a
young assistant professor of philosophy
and afro-american studies as it was then
called books by young philosophers were
very rare in those days they're pretty
rare even now but within five years
professor Apia had published not one but
two books assertion and conditionals
with Cambridge University Press in 1985
and truth and semantics with Blackwell's
in Oxford of night in 1985 had been
promoted to associate professor and
offered tenure clearly his was a mind on
the move alas Apia left Yale in 1986 and
began to take up a series of positions
at some of our nation's finest
universities none of which has proved
able to secure Apia permanently Cornell
Duke Harvard Princeton and now NYU where
he has been since 2014 as professor of
philosophy and law Anthony Appiah has
shown an intellectual restlessness that
has matched his peripatetic professional
life within philosophy alone he's done
important work in philosophy of mind and
language social philosophy the
philosophy of race moral and political
philosophy in the history of moral and
political ideas experimental philosophy
and a variety of others
he's also ventured far outside of
philosophy to critical social theory
literature intellectual biography
writing of novels short stories and
poetry and most recently what we might
call moral journalism holding down the
ethicist column in The New York Times
magazine since October 2015 his books
most famously cosmopolitanism ethics in
a world of strangers the ethics of
identity in my father's house color
conscious and the honor code have been
widely translated and highly honored
cosmopolitanism for example has been
translated into some 15 languages by my
count and the honor code appeared on
both the New York Times in The Times
Literary Supplement
lists of major books in 2010 epi has
also been highly honored himself as
befits a world expert on honor having
received some 16 honorary degrees
including at Harvard pan Columbia it's
worth more Edinboro and many others
epiha now turns his omnivorous
intellectual attention to reflection on
religion the endowment for the Terry
lectures calls for quote the building of
the truths of science and philosophy
into the structure of a broadened and
purified religion we at Yale have had
the good fortune to benefit from Anthony
a pious thoughts on the anatomy of
religion today he continues with
religion after Darwin before we welcome
professor Apia let me please remind you
to turn off your cell phones and other
mediating devices and invite you to join
us after the lecture for a reception in
the room at the other end of the hall
and now please join me in welcoming
Anthony Appiah
[Applause]
it's okay that was very kind thank you
very much
so I want at the end of the series now
and the last lecture just to thank that
Harry elected committee again for
inviting me and giving me bit of time to
think about it what I was going to say
and align me therefore to to develop
some new ideas I hope about about how to
think about religion from the ideas for
me over the last couple of years
let's begin by retracing some of our
steps so Edward Tylor taking us human
beings as we are found our over
projection of the intentional stance
quite natural
we believed in spirit he thought because
it was a reasonable hypothesis
evans-pritchard one of Tyler's heirs
explained that we were dealing with a
proto scientific hypothesis which
postulated spirits rather than
impersonal forces or atoms behind the
appearances if there was a puddle about
rituals it wasn't by our relations with
which with spirits were ceremonious but
why our relations with each other were
for granted the ceremonious and symbolic
character of our relations with humans
the extension of ceremony to non-human
beings was also quite natural and those
Tyler didn't stress this the strong
feeling associated with much religious
thought and action fits with the general
animist hypothesis feeling is a feature
of our relations with humans who matter
to us why shouldn't it be there in our
dealings with significant spirits as
well still the focus was very much on
individual belief and its consequences
for behavior most of what he says about
religion could have been said about
Robinson Crusoe before Friday joined in
on that fictional island and even then
the presence of another person would
have added to belief in ritual only the
results of their communicating with one
another Max Weber and Emile Durkheim on
the other hand were interested again
taking us as we are in what religion
means not for individuals but
Society both began with the imputations
of special people and objects of a
distinctive power associated with
charisma for Weber or the sacred for
Durkheim Taylor thinks animism is an
intuitive idea for Weber charisma arises
from the experience of spectacular
individuals heroes or prophets whose
exploits reach beyond the ordinary and
he presents this somewhat less plausibly
I think as an intuitive idea - we
imagine there must be something special
about these charismatic people some
power that explains their extraordinary
exploits if their exploits cease we may
wonder if we were right or whether the
power has left so it's important for
people in died with charisma to be able
to keep convincing us of their powers in
Weber religion begins when charisma
becomes the tool of specialist magicians
working on their own but eventually
charisma becomes the domain of a
priesthood professional practitioners of
what he called a continuously operating
cult this is when full fledge religion
arrives religion is intrinsically
institutional and even the human soul is
discovered first in the social activity
of the orgy those of you who weren't
here will make that'll sound more
exciting than it actually is he's
talking about the religion of the Greeks
so these are ceremonial gatherings at
which individuals come together out of
their profane lives into a community
that addresses the sacred in the
psychological excitement produced there
the collective effervescence as the clan
called it of the Aboriginal corroboree
people dancing together to the
accompaniment of music experience a loss
of individuality a sense of social union
the spirits are forces whose existence
is imagined through these periods of
this individuation and they symbolize
the social union of the group religious
claims literally articulated as false
claims about the persons and powers
associated with sacred objects expressed
symbolically the truths about
and our dependence on it and these
rituals not only Express the social
Union they help to generate and sustain
it so but they're kind religion is
multiplied social religious belief
begins in social experiences it is
fundamentally about society and society
is sustained by religious behavior by
ritual the Union created by religious
ritual he called a church and for him no
church no society and Moses a tea no
spirits religious beliefs were social -
they were what he called collective
representations there are time agreed
with Aristotle and with count and I
mentioned them not because I'm a
philosopher because he mentions
Aristotle and Gantt exquisitely that
there were fundamental categories of
thought which were the precondition of
our having any beliefs at all Kant saw
that they were the products of reason
their time argued instead that they were
the products of society our ways of
thinking about time and space for
example grew out of the cycle of the
festivals and the division between
sacred and profane places even though
Durkheim asserts every religion is true
gods spirits and totems though essential
parts of the ontology of the sacred are
not real the sacred is an imaginary
projection of the social Tyler doesn't
even consider the possibility that most
of the spirits who talked about a real
Weber thinks that religion produces
paradoxes beliefs that are strictly
speaking literally incomprehensible so
couldn't be true recall that he thinks
that in the end the intellectual life of
the believer must end up with something
like Italians crowd boast about the
Incarnation
I believe it he said queer in Epton
because it is absurd all are serious
amount of their time they were
developing a science of religion but in
their era people and especially those
who thought of themselves as scientists
were increasingly skeptical of spirits
they were each raised in one of the
branches of Western European monotheism
a Quaker a Calvinist a Jew
Tylor remained the remember of the
Society of Friends his entire life even
if Weber and Durkheim were not as the
so practical but even if they had been
committed to their own religious
traditions they aim to give an account
of all religions from the earliest times
to the present that could not have taken
so they could not have taken the claims
of all of them with equal seriousness
since these claims are literally
incompatible if they were going to
explain all religions they were going to
have to do so without adhering to them
and since adherence required for all of
them belief in spirits that meant that
they could not appeal to the reality of
spirits in explaining religion in this
respect these founding fathers of the
modern sciences of religion were typical
of a kind of intellectual that appears
increasingly in the cultures of a North
Atlantic in the century that followed
their deaths I could have added Karl
Marx who famously argued that religion
was the opium of the people a source of
waking fantasies that distracted people
from the reality of their situation
giving them solace but depriving them of
the energy to resist oppression whatever
they themselves believed these men took
it for granted that religion like
humanity itself must have evolved we
could give a scientific account of the
development of its of the development of
both that is humanity and religion which
meant for them an account that did not
appeal to spiritual agency now there is
an obvious alternative explanation for
belief in gods and spirits it is that
they are there and people have noticed
them ritual to who can be conceived of
or the appropriate response to their
existence if we took the religious
experiences people report at face value
some of them anyway we could suppose
that many people are capable of a
special kind of perception perhaps when
in a special ecstatic state which might
be induced by rituals like chanting or
by meditation or by drugs like peyote or
alcohol that special perception we can
hypothesize reveals to us the presence
in the world around us of many spirits
or of the one true spirit exactly that
explanation was being given at the very
moment that the founding fathers of our
sciences of religion were at work by
another group of men and women who also
explored the religious lives of others
they were the missionaries who came in
the wake of Europe's empires the large
parts of Asia Africa and the Americas
living in the very societies about which
the first anthropologists were writing
often providing the materials that they
used to think about them where they
found as they often did evidence of
belief in what was called a high God
associated with the heavens the sort of
monarch of the spiritual world described
by Tyler they took this as evidence that
the locals had recognized however and
perfectly the existence of the God of
Abraham and Isaac and Isaac and Jacob
as for nature spirits or totemic gods
these were either idols man-made objects
mistakenly believed to contain or
represent a lesser divinity or the
powers for which the New Testament uses
the words diamond ear and no matter
which the King James Bible translated as
Devils and spirits I'll return to some
reflections on what we might call the
methodological atheism of the Sciences
of religion at the end but it has
continued even those scientists of
religion to identify as religious like
the great mathematical biologists Martin
Nowak professor of biology and
mathematics and director of a program
for evolution dynamics of Harvard
explore the evolution of human
sociability in general and of religion
in particular without appealed to God
like Laplace in the celebrated if
apocryphal conversation with Napoleon
some two centuries ago they have no need
of that hypothesis as I've insisted our
three theorists assume human psychology
and ask given that psychology how
religious belief an action arrives after
Darwin we see human psychology as itself
something to be explained we can ask why
there are creatures like us not taking
us as they did as we are but asking how
we come to be this way two general
questions central questions then suggest
themselves first the question invited by
Tyler's animist hypothesis why are there
creatures that apply the intentional
stance over broadly and second the
question made natural by Weber and
Durkheim what about religious behavior
is that it what explains
it's a Zayat survival what explains its
role in sustaining society religion
seems to be as the evolutionary
psychologists would say agreeing with
Durkheim but using their own word
profoundly pro-social helping to bind
human beings to society supporting the
sacrifice of individual interests for
the common good but the very existence
of pro-social behavior is a problem for
the synthesis of Darwinian natural
selection and Mendelian genetics for if
pro-social behavior means risking our
own survival for the survival of others
then that seems at odds with this modern
at odds with this modern synthesis
natural selection are a picture made
famous by or made familiar by Richard
Dawkins is the result of selfish genes
and the survival of the fittest is a
success of individuals not of groups
there's an obvious response to the claim
of a conflict within the plain evidence
of our sociability and a theory on which
that sociability is fatal if a gene
leaves the behavior that risks my death
but increases the survival prospects of
others who also carry it as mendez
mentalism predicts that many of my kin
spoke certainly will then it can
proliferate by natural selection that's
called kin selection first described in
the 1950s by JVs all things but we
humans with our unique gift of language
are capable of transmitting behavior
through culture as well as through our
genes this transmission depends on an
innate individual psychology which is
then shaped by the interaction of each
person's vedic endowment with our human
experience that I now makes a cultural
evolution though are very different from
the Mendelian ideas and practices
unlike genes can spread to people who
are not closely genetically related they
can go from children to parents and not
just comparing the children they can die
out without anyone dying and then
through the magic of writing we appear
the modern science of religion appeals
to the ways in which our individual
psychologists were shaped by genetic
selection but can appeal to cultural
evolution with its different logic as
well drawing on what
Tyler remember calls the capabilities
and habits acquired by man as a member
of society in defining the subject
matter of anthropology even genetic
explanations of our psychological
development across the ages do not have
to appeal only the kin selection to
secure sociability more speculatively
since the mathematics and the models
here are controversial though some of
the reviews are the same Martin Novak
through it's a very distinguished
mathematician and I'll just so have some
confidence that he might be right more
speculative you could argue that
selection operates at the level of
groups so this competing groups like
themselves be like individuals units of
selection still nothing in the most
Orthodox Darwinian picture rules out the
idea that some behavior transmitted not
phonetically but socially will aided
survival of social groups so that their
success involves not the selection of
genes or of individuals sort of patterns
of action the constraint set by
Darwinism is that these forms of
behavior should be consistent with our
evolved psychology that's not much of a
constraint and both these ideas group
selection and cultural evolution fit
naturally with the perspectives of Weber
and Durkheim because they focus on the
ways in which religious behavior can be
pro-social sustaining the survival of
the communities in which it occurs let's
just consider two representative recent
attempts to explain aspects of the
evolution of religion which display
Tyler Ian barbarian and their community
sure's I'll begin with the story that
explains the origins of the feature of
our evolved psychology that Tyler took
for granted our propensity to overextend
the intentional strategy that is to find
agents in places where on a modern
scientific view there aren't any the
vocabularies of anthropology philosophy
and evolutionary psychology are of
course often different so rather than
talking about the intentional psychology
strategy as we philosophers might or
talking about belief in spirits as Tyler
did evolutionary psychologists subscribe
to the evolved psychology of most modern
human beings what they call in their
charming way and agent detection device
most brains are so formed they think
that we have a module that needs us to
respond to a wide range of experiences
by attributing agency to something in
the world very often of course that
something is a person an actual agent
and we understand agents by applying to
them a folk psychological theory that
supposes that they have beliefs desires
and feelings evolutionary psychology
calls that theory of mind theory of mind
it's pretty successful in helping us
predict and make sense of the behavior
of others and of course ourselves it's
easy to see why the complex of genes
necessary to transmit the capacity to
develop an agent of detection device
might have evolved in a social animal
making sense of others is crucial to
individual survival if we are in fact
agents creatures that can form more or
less to the folk psychological theory of
agency then being able to apply that
theory will help you get us right but to
do that you'll have to detect agents in
the first place you'll have to be aware
that they're there precisely because we
are social creatures dependent on
coordinating our behavior with others
individual survival will be enhanced by
the possession of that device but this
doesn't explain why it increases the
Darwinian fitness of individuals to have
what is being called a hyperactive
agency detection device the feature of
our psychology that Tylor relied on why
that is should our tendency to ascribe
agency have evolved to be triggered so
often by things that are not in fact
agents why should it behave precisely
the way Tylor supposed well here's a
recent proposal due to Dominic Thompson
it begins as all the theories we have so
far considered do with methodological
atheism there is no God you might think
it follows that there could be no
individual selective advantage to be
gained from believing in it you would be
wrong Johnson argues in God's absence
the very heavy investment in the
activity of the durkheimian church is
clearly going to disadvantaged
individuals prayer takes time away from
farming or hunting taboos limit diet and
raise the cost of nutrition and priests
and temples need expensive support so
far we've Ellucian airily speaking so
bad
but suppose the advantages outweigh
these admittedly significant costs well
Johnson has a story about why they might
begin with another example of a habit of
human beings that leads to error it
turns out that we're far more likely to
mistake sticks for snakes than the other
way around why should that be well
because the costs of mistaking a snake
for a stick are almost always way more
serious than the costs of mistaking a
stick for a snake
no detector whether produced by
evolution or human design will be
perfect it will make two kinds of errors
sometimes it will fail to detect the
presence of something it should a false
negative sometimes it will mistakenly
announce the presence of something it
shouldn't a false positive in general
then according to what is called error
management theory a well-designed
detector should avoid the mistakes that
are most costly had the expensive
necessary of increasing the rate of the
less costly kind of error in the case of
snake detection the higher cost mistake
is the false negative the hypothesis
that a hyperactive agency detection
device can be adaptive requires that the
less expensive error is the false
positive that Y Johnson's answer starts
with a solution to another problem about
the evolution of sociability the
development of complex societies clearly
requires a great deal of cooperation a
recent line of literature demonstrates
with mathematical models that one way to
support this is by establishing an
inclination that in fact exists in most
human beings to punish those who breach
social norms even when we are not
ourselves the victims so we have this
tendency to punish people who breach
social norms whether or not they've done
any harm to us the bottom line is that
it's reasonable to defect from a social
norm in many contexts only if you can
reduce the costs of detection because
when human beings detect social norm
breaches in others they often make them
pay a heavy cost now among the many
significant consequences of the
development of theory of mind and of
language
sorry of theory mind and language are
these people get better at identifying
the motivations of others including
their incentives to defect and they're
able through language to communicate the
fact of detection to others the result
is that in creatures like us which means
us because there aren't any creatures
and this was kept like us on this planet
anyway the risks associated with
defection are significantly higher than
in social creatures with neither
language nor theory of mind even if you
think you're not being watched you may
be or others may infer your defection
from its traces including its later
traces in your own behavior you may
think you will get away with the live
example but the cognitive task of
keeping track of your lives can be high
and may eventually show you up and not
only is the likelihood of detection
higher and creatures like us its costs
are significantly higher - since they
extend to the responses not just that
those who witness or infer our defection
but potentially to all those with whom
they can communicate in these
circumstances the cost of wrongly
thinking that defections will escape
discovery are very high and may be
higher than the costs of conformity
these circumstances Johnson argues there
may be individual selective advantage
the winning advantage in having a
tendency not to defect and being
inclined that is to do things that are
good for the community and genuinely
biologically costly because the expected
imposed social costs of detective
defection are so high and believes in
invisible spirits would be a mechanism
for securing such pro-social behavior
because of course if the spirits are
always around and can be invisible and
it's like human beings they can both
punish you and communicate your
defections to others you will always
worry that defection risks detection and
punishment so this is an argument for
the proposition that pylori and animism
is the consequence of a hyperactive
agency detection device that is
individually selectively advantageous
because we cannot be sure that we will
evade detection even whether we when we
think whether rightly or wrongly that
there's no one around not because the
spirits are in the watching of course
but because human beings equipped with
theory of mind and with language are way
more likely to learn about and punish
our defections then is true among our
fellow primates that's one explanation
here's another example of an explanation
of the development of a feature of
belief in spirits that involves cultural
rather than biological evolution such
explanations must start with features of
our evolved psychology leading it to
others to explain why they evolved the
explanation I want to consider comes
from work by Joseph Henry and Scott
action it begins with a hypothesis for
which there's a great deal of
cross-cultural evidence that we come
into the world with predispositions to
develop an intuitive ontology basic set
of structures for thinking about the
world around us the idea of an agent and
with it the associated theory of mind is
only one of these we naturally classify
the world into agents and non agents
animals and plants living and nonliving
things with the plants and animals goes
a folk biology with the nonliving things
of folk physics and so on
now sometimes cultures develop the idea
of an entity that violates some of these
intuitive structures human beings for
example are agents and we are living
things
agents occupy space and living things
die but angels ghosts and spirits as
Henry connection point out violate these
assumptions they are and I quote Asians
that resemble us emotionally
intellectually and physically except
that they can move through solid objects
and live forever stories with small
numbers of such violations which produce
what they call minimally
counterintuitive representations are
easier to remember than those with none
but also than stories with too many
folktales which had to be remembered and
passed on in oral cultures often have
entities with such minimal violations a
talking lion a living Mountain but these
are stories we remember but we don't
necessarily believe so they're memorable
because they've been minimally counter
it is counter intuitive representations
are memorable but they're not believable
you don't believe
when you hear when you hear your parents
talking about a talking line and lion in
the folk story you're likely to think
okay this is this is not this is a
storytelling it's not true once we have
cultural transmissions we get two
additional things for free
one is the possibility of the
accumulation of knowledge and the
development of concepts remote from our
intuitive ontology the other is the
possibility that we will be misinformed
by others credulous a tendency to
believe others would allow us to take
advantage of the former the accumulation
of knowledge but also make us more
susceptible to exploitation by the
latter misinformation quote the full
Language Learners observed and inferred
people's underlying beliefs or desires
by their behavior those wishing to
deceive would have to actually perform
an action to transmit it in quote all
the split infinitives in this talk are
in quotation mark once language is
available manipulation is possible
without action I can get you to act on a
false idea without risking the costs of
acting on it myself whereas among chimps
most ways of getting other chimps to do
things involve doing something and
getting them to copy you as we say aping
so you should take care because other
human beings can get you to do things
that they wouldn't do themselves because
they can try to mislead you you should
take care not to rely on others unless
there's a good reason to do so and one
good reason is seeing them acting on
their beliefs so these are our authors
argue we should have evolved mechanisms
culturally evolved mechanist mechanisms
aimed at testing belief against action
before accepting the claims of others
quote in figuring out who to learn from
learners considered both are models cues
of success skill and prestige among
other cues and whether our models
express beliefs are supported by
diagnostic actions that permit an
assessment of the models on the ground
degree of commitment to them so once
mechanisms like these are in place
counterintuitive propositions of the
sort associated with religion like
angels which can do things that ordinary
agents can't do can be both memorized
they're already memorable because
they're minimally counterintuitive and
believed provided those who transmit
them are able to communicate the right
cues the cues that lead us to believe
them having tested them against our
mechanisms for testing other people's
claims and counterintuitive beliefs
associated with demanding rituals may
have been easier to transmit to new
learners because such behavior signals
that the existing adherents are
genuinely committed to them in cultural
evolution patterns of thought and action
that are more likely to reproduce
themselves through transmission across
space and time replacing existing
patterns of behavior survived provided
they don't reduce the survival rates of
those groups culturally transmitted
patterns of behavior unlike genetically
transmitted ones do not have to increase
the individual fitness of their members
if these beliefs and practices add to
social cohesion they can also allow one
group to compete others that lack them
so Henry connection do not say with
their kind that rituals and
counterintuitive of these they sustain
express truths about Society religious
thought and action does reflect if they
are right the fact that society requires
individual sacrifice precisely because
they help to sustain those sacrifices
that make society possible and what they
complex society is possible and what
they mean by religion these scientists
is not just the belief in non-human
agency that is a mark of religion in
every one of the classical theories we
considered but also their combination
with rituals institutions and support
for pro-social behavior all of which
mattered as you know to labor under
account so this explanation supports
labor and Durkheim against Tyler who
thought that religion and ethics
pro-social norms where
separate in primitive societies this is
valid if it's correct like the founding
fathers of the social sciences is a
religion modern evolutionary
psychologists have conceptions of
religion they include belief in spirits
as we just saw in these two cases the
idea of counterintuitive concepts the
endorsement of pro-social norms and
ritual behavior and none of this would
have surprised the founders but in the
actual explanations of which I've just
offered a representative flavor each of
these elements needs to be identified
separately to do its explanatory work in
religions where one or the other was
absent parts of the explanation could
still be appeal to just as invaders
account of the Protestant ethic the idea
of religion doesn't play an explanatory
role so in Johnson's account why error
management theory suggests you might
have a hyperactive agent detection
device what's needed is just beliefs in
social in invisible agents and
pro-social behavior you don't need
anything else to get that explanation to
work so you don't need many of the
things that are in fact characteristic
of the things we call religions Tyler's
concept of spirit wavers charisma
Durkheim's idea of the sacred are far
from luminously clear and without
clarity it's hard to say what could
count wisely for them as religion indeed
if one tries to sort out these
difficulties by looking in more detail
at the way they extend their central
concepts into difficult cases one
discovers I think that trying to cover
all the cases as they do stretches their
central concepts to breaking point these
difficulties are very evident in their
own text as I want to show now briefly
by considering what each of them has to
say has to have to pass to say in order
to bring Buddhism into their frameworks
Buddhism as they understand it this is
not my body than this tears
Tyler recognizes that at the very least
some Buddhists do not appear to believe
in the human souls which obviously makes
difficulties for a theory that proposes
that religion begins by extending the
idea of the human soul out into the
nonhuman world
so he's supposed to say that even if the
Buddhists and I quote refine away into
metaphysical subtleties the notion the
continued personality they didn't
consistently and systematically hold
that a man's life in former existences
is the cause of his now being what he is
while at this moment he is accumulating
merit or demerit his results will
determine his fate in future lives so
he's saying that Buddhists share the
Hindu doctrine of karma but this as the
lawyer say is non-responsive if the
mechanism of karma does not involve
spirits then Buddhism is not a tellurium
religion analogous problems arise for
Weber the Dalai Lama would like that
he's always joking that he's gonna be
the biggest pious leader in the world
today analogous problems arise for Weber
he concedes that in ancient Buddhism
quote the soul is totally eliminated and
that there is only the mechanism of
karma it is a doctrine of salvation but
recognizes no God he says the Lord
governed operation of karma seems far
away from charisma as an extraordinary
force and Durkheim recognized as we saw
that the sacred in Buddhism was reduced
to the Four Noble Truths and the rituals
founded on them but where then is the
Buddhist church a church being an
essential element of religion for third
time these difficulties are just meant
to be representative I promised the
press that there will be many more
examples of them in the book and these
challenges in dealing with an ancient
and dispersed literate civilization are
compounded if we add in the more local
so-called traditional religions of
Africa in the santi where I grew up in
the mid 19th century people had all
sorts of beliefs about Nami the sky gods
and Cecilia the earth goddess and other
spirits of many kinds there were ritual
practices and prayers and professional
priests and shrines of varying degrees
of sophistication ranging from the
domestic to the national nevertheless it
would never have occurred to people to
define themselves as belonging to a
tradition compounded of ritual
the leaf those things we now call Asante
religion were a constituent of everyday
life and there is no word in 19th
century of Santa tree as in most of the
world's religions world languages until
recently that well translates our word
religion thinking about this I came many
years ago to a conclusion for these
earlier theorists of religion it's a
real question as they look out from
Europe on the wider world of this what
did they have instead of Christianity
there was a clue here in Babers
references to Confucianism in the
sociology of religion would serve mostly
to introduce a contrast with the world
of charisma or the world of priesthood
for the Confucian literati are not
priests they are not professionally
engaged in cult in worship and their
role is to manage society not through
magic but through extraordinary powers
but through a rational intellectual
system so you might ask why he refers to
them at all well the answer if I'm right
is simple the Chinese society over many
millennia
Confucianism some of the social
functions that Christianity served where
he lived and if that is right it won't
be surprising that religion is a
paradigm of what began Stein taught us
to call the family resemblance concept
each religion like each member of a
family is no doubt like every other in
some respects but there need be no
distinctive characteristics they all
share remember what Weber said the
essence of religion is absolutely not
our concern that's a good thing if
religion doesn't have an essence I
learned recently that the great
comparative religion is William Cantwell
Smith reached this conclusion before I
did it cheers me up tonight managed to
reach it on my own quote the religious
is that which has been called religious
in the West Western world created
Christian and Jewish matters and
anything else on earth that can be shown
to be comparable the Christianity that
surrounded our three founding fathers
were the set of traditions that have
been shaped over millennia but their
sources for thinking about religion
outside the great literate traditions
were largely materials assembled by
Europeans in
global expansion since 1492 and by and
large they had called anything a
religion that was in competition with
the Christian ideas practices and
traditions they left behind the result
is that many people in our intellectual
tradition unwittingly take as the
paradigm of religion one particular set
of religious sects those have developed
out of medieval prison them in the
coincidence of the Age of Exploration
and the Reformation that's why for
example belief in God and the soul is
taken to be one mark of religion even
though as we've seen there are a
theistic forms of Buddhism that have no
place for either God or the soul a
Christian model of religion is going to
look for more than Creed's it would
expect churches priests prayer
collective worship moral codes and yes
charisma and the sacred it will reject
magic even when it practices it and it
may pay less attention to things that
people in other traditions might think
obviously important dietary rules or
ancestral cults which had largely
disappeared in European Christianity by
the end of the nineteenth century to be
sure the founders were also educated
European gentlemen so they knew their
classics so they would also have
included what Cicero or Lucretius meant
by the word religio I started by talking
about that but that is part of the
parallel story Christianity inherited
the word religion because it replaced
what the Romans called religio but
there's no word for Christianity in the
New Testament of course there is the
truth there is the way there is the law
and there are the Jewish Scriptures
Jesus calls the law and the prophets the
word the King James Bible Translators
religion in the New Testament it's a
word which means etymologically fear of
gods or fear of spirits and it doesn't
apply the Christianity William Cantwell
Smith points out that again tweaking to
him again points out that Hinduism isn't
a Hindu concept either the first step
that one must take towards understanding
something of the vision of the Hindus he
says that the mass of religious
phenomena that we shelter under the
Umbra
that is not a unity and does not aspire
to be it is not an entity in any
theoretical sense let alone a tactical
one the modeling of all the world's
religions on modern Christianity can
therefore be profoundly misleading
looking out across the world certain
things naturally struck our founders
what some people appeared to have
instead of Christianity was what
Durkheim called totemism from the word
totem which came into European languages
from Ojibwa voodoo demon which means
family but also family emblem family
mark among American Indians Aborigines
and many Africans clans were associated
with animals or plants the ethnographic
details of durkheim's account of
aboriginal practices are now widely
agreed to be unreliable but it remains
true that such a pattern obtains my own
father belonged to one of eight a kin
maternal descent groups or mattre clans
associated with the bush cow known in
our language as a corner so that's a
pattern that they noticed across the
world
here's another pattern recognizable to
the founders because of their classical
education there are myths in which named
human-like gods associated with specific
cults and functions are found in Inca
Norse Yoruba as well as Greek and Roman
thought not surprisingly they are
associated in all these places with
kingship even among those Greeks like
the Athenians who didn't practice it
freeing paradigms suggest themselves to
account for patterns like these one is a
diffusion but the historical distance
between the inker and the Yoruba is vast
as is the distance between Leah can my
father's people and Australian
Aborigines modern humans left Africa
some hundred thousand years ago and the
Americas were first populated only
twenty or thirty thousand years ago they
may well have been no cultural
connections between Inca and Yoruba
ancestors more recently than 45,000
years ago the ancestors of Australian
Aboriginal II is probably less Africa
seventy-five thousand years ago arriving
in Australia
45,000 years ago so even if every
society in Africa had planned with
associated plans or animals the
persistence of this pattern over that
long period especially without writing
would be astonishing a second
explanation then would be the one that
occurred to Tyler human beings have
basically the same evolved psychology
faced with the same world why shouldn't
it produce similar results everywhere
and finally we can add to our repertoire
of explanatory strategies the thought
that Weber and Durkheim added that with
language and the development of social
institutions that it makes possible we
have not just the same psychology and a
similar natural environment but
similarities in social experience as
well we're going to model we're going to
model the spirits on something you'll
model them on social structures if you
will have to trick your model Ramon
Kings so the fact that many many high
gods are referred to in the sort of
language of use for Kings is completely
unsurprising on that few but it's not
the result of the fact that they all
derive it from the same place it's not
the result of diffusion but in all these
explanations it's not religion that does
the work the concept it's spirits or
cult or priesthood or something more
specific and the point is that these can
be put together in very different
packages Faber's great classic the
prosthetic did not need as I've already
said the idea of religion charisma
spirit of sacred work for some cases but
not for all religion isn't a global
concept in part for this reason in the
contemporary world some collections of
beliefs and rituals and norms are
associated with an identity and these
get called religions when they're
sufficiently like some of the paradigms
which now evidently include atheistic
Buddhism still Confucianism doesn't get
to be a religion for many because it's
low on gods and priests which are
associated with something else which is
called Taoism and that distinction is I
think very much not clearly one of sort
of making the Chinese is making and then
what Confucius teaches is about
is away neither Hinduism nor Buddhism is
one religion each involves a diverse set
of pictures loosely reflecting elements
that could be found somewhere in the
sanskrit and pali scriptures associated
sometimes with ritual practices again
very diverse and a superstructure of
festivals widely recognized and a
priestly caste overseeing much of it and
engage with the scriptures but
Christianity too is of course many
different things
bringing together elements from a bundle
of options none of which is found in all
the branches tyler's Quakerism did not
have much place the charisma of the
sacred or taboos the Judaism of
durkheim's father and grandfather were
surely more concerned with although
proxy than with orthodoxy the thing that
is right in the founders methods is that
these configurations are best understood
historically by seeing how the various
elements in one tradition like Calvinism
in Faber's great classic come together
and the improvements of methods from
Tyler to Weber and Durkheim included the
recognition that social institutions
vapers priesthood store accounts
churches play in a central role in such
histories these two elements are there
as we've seen today in modern
evolutionary accounts as well but as I
insisted they don't need the unitary
concept of a religion either separating
our discussions of religious
institutions in particular places from
scientific ones for example insisting on
a distinction invented not long before
sociology and anthropology were
beginning in Europe isn't really helpful
in understanding the traditional culture
of a shanty indeed it isn't much help in
understanding the historical development
of European science the truth in the
apocryphal story that Laplace told
Napoleon to which I had Berta curlier
the claim that the past said Napoleon II
had no need of the god hypothesis the
truth in that is surely that Laplace did
spend a great deal of intellectual
energy as a mathematician refuting the
idea which had been around since Newton
that God's intervention was necessary to
guarantee the stability
other system and indeed which is
something that worried Newton a lot and
indeed Laplace made many contributions
to the mathematical problem of modeling
the Newtonian dynamics of the solar
system though disturbingly I discovered
in preparing for this his work did not
prove what he thought and so far as I
know the question whether the solar
system is stable there's still a
mathematically open one so if we
suddenly shoot off in some direction we
can't say that receives Newton when we
approach a society that is not around
seeking to understand its thoughts and
practices in the scientific way we will
always have to begin with an enterprise
of translation so for fans begins as
Weber insisted with first an
understanding in the conceptual world of
those whose behavior we seek to explain
the sociology of a Christian society
would naturally use Christian concepts
to try to make sorry the sociologist of
a Christian society will naturally use
Christian concepts to try and make sense
of non-christian ones but translation
isn't just mapping concepts into
concepts its triangulating both with
reality let me explain this point let me
just briefly offer an example from the
history of chemistry from the point of
view of current theory late 18th century
chemistry looks as though it classified
some things acids and bases say by and
large correctly even if a lot of what
they said about those things was pretty
badly wrong also from the point of view
of current theory an acid is roughly a
proton donor and our recognition of the
fact that the classification of acids
and bases was in itself an intellectual
achievement is recorded in the fact that
we're inclined to say that when Antoine
Lavoisier who not having any idea of the
proton could hardly be expected to have
understood the notion of a proton donor
when he used the word acid he was
nevertheless talking about what we still
still cool acid he was talking about
proton domes
the issue here is at the intersection of
the Philosopher's language and the
philosophy of science in explaining why
it seems proper to think that Lavoisier
was referring to things we call proton
day
even though much of what he believed
about acids is not true of proton donors
philosophers of science have borrowed
ideas from the causal theory of
reference in the philosophy of language
the proposal is simple enough if you
want to know what object a word refers
to find the thing in the world that
gives the best causal explanation of the
central features of the use of that word
if you want to know what the name New
York refers to find the object in the
world that is the root of most of the
causal chains that lead to remarks
containing the expression New York with
acids because we believe that the stuffs
out there in the world that really
accounted for the central features of
Lavoisier's acid talk really were acids
we concluded that he wasn't simply
talking about something else or about
nothing at all early neurophysiologists
like decaf on the other hand who talked
about animal spirits in the nerve fibers
we now say we're referring to nothing at
all there is no currently recognised
stuff but can account for what they said
about animal spirits instead there are
truths about sodium pumps and lipid
bilayers and sign apses there simply is
no substance that was usually present
when and only when the expression animal
spirits was uttered and that behaves at
all as they thought animal spirits
behave now a sounds formed on this model
by Christian believers might proceed as
the missionary's I mentioned earlier did
mapping the ontology z' of their
societies as closely as they could into
their own then taking their own ontology
as given they could try to tell the
story of the growth and development of
Islam or Buddhism or the traditional
religions of Asante or Australia or the
Andes now I think there's a reason the
sciences of religion can't be like this
and it has to do with the ethos of
science Tylor Weber Durkheim three
Nations three religious traditions three
languages in dialogue science aims to be
a discourse that transcends local
identities which is deeply cosmopolitan
to offer a local metaphysics in this
basis would produce a discourse that was
not recognizable as a contribution to
the cosmopolitan conversation
of the sciences this is one reason why
Soviet ideas of socialist science which
inspired like senko or the even worse
nerdy inspired ideas of a German science
belong somewhere intellectual history
but don't really belong in the history
of the sciences this cosmopolitan ideal
the calling of the scientist on the one
hand and the demands are sustained on
the other can therefore call in
different directions here first an
requires us to appeal to our own
concepts but not to our own truths in
the explanations though true the
universal shared reality has to matter
because the scientific story of religion
has to work for all people's peoples of
all faiths and none but as we saw with
our VA we may need to appeal to the
truth to figure out which of our
concepts provides the best local analog
of the ideas of the stranger so the
distinction isn't so sharp
precisely because concepts presuppose
truths if there really are no spirits
many conceptual questions about spirits
don't make much sense of a material can
they be in two places at once
what would that mean once you sense the
paradoxes here you may lose your grip on
the concept you may decide it is like
Descartes animal spirits and not like
acid as we've seen now of everything we
call a religion will have Christianity's
laser-like focus on ontological truth
claims but so long as there are people
making ontological truth claims in the
name of religion there will be the
possibility of a tension between the
very idea of a science of religion and
some of the great assemblages of beliefs
practices and institutions but make up
what we call the religious life
[Applause]
okay see I was interested in the
evolutionary explanation of belief in
spirits and so on to try to keep
conformity and then I was also
interested in the characterization of
Confucianism as rationale and so I was
wondering well how how you think this
works in China and what explains why in
some settings we get the personalized
version of the spirits and in other
cultures not that's a great question and
I sometimes when you say something's
great question it means because you have
a great answer sometimes it means you're
not sure what the answer is I think it's
the latter in this case I mean look and
if you were a 19th century Qing Dynasty
literati I do not believe the world came
to you packaged as that wisdom and
Confucianism you were a scholar of what
we call the Confucian classics which
include texts of wind written by
Confucius and and you spent much of your
life studying those and those those
texts while they do presuppose a kind of
vague sense that you might call
religious of the universe's of all under
heaven as being a kind of category
that's really absolutely not the focus
even when Confucius is defending what we
would call rituals
early he's first of all that's a bad
translation is the standard translation
but he's talking about good manners he's
talking yes about proper behavior
towards the representations of your
ancestors in the domestic which we would
recognize as a ritual he's talking about
a whole range of it were proper normal
behaviors how people should normally
behave and that that's the focus I mean
the idea is and that includes of course
proper what we would think of as ethical
stuff that is includes the fact that the
emperor should look after the subject
the older brother should be respected by
the younger brother the fathers and so
on filial piety all these things so it's
just you know you could take the
references to heaven and all that stuff
out and it's almost all exactly the same
it's a bit like the way we often read
Plato I mean you know we don't often
focus I mean some people write about
Plato's theology but on the whole we
think we can read a lot of the Socratic
texts anyway completely indifferent ly
to the question of the human spirit so
Weber had a had a view about about why
the the Confucian literati were like
were the way they were part of it had to
do with the fact that they ran the state
they were not just they were not
bureaucrat of a cult they were arrogant
and also they had a lot of social
Authority and they didn't really need
the emperor had charisma but but what an
ordinary litter artists in the provinces
was doing was not as religion was
supposed to be for labor the management
of charisma it was running the office as
a magistrate and you know giving orders
and writing beautiful memoranda to go to
to go back to the Emperor so I don't
know if that explains why they but it is
it's what he says about it is that
and I think it's true that that's that
kind of I mean he mentions the so you
could you could think also about that
case and then you could think about the
the pharaonic Egypt which also has a
vast bureaucracy but which we do think I
was contesting for priests though its
main function was to run from mistake
and and they were very very powerful
just as the literati in a certain sense
control the emperor in reality it's not
in symbolism so they controlled CC
pharaohs and when AG mountain tried to
change things he lost and the pharaohs
were beaten by the priests so so I don't
think it's a very good explanation thank
you very much for a really interesting
and presentation and especially the
presentation of various evolutionary
ways of thinking about religious
phenomena which I take to be if I'm
reading you're right just as
unsuccessful about giving an anatomy of
religion as their predecessors given
that it is there an anatomy of religion
or just the impossibility of finding it
I think that so sometimes what I'm
inclined to say is it's not a very
helpful concept that if you want to use
the word use it in the places where
people use the word like that
Cicero talks about religion we can see
what he's talking about we can figure it
out and we can understand what it is and
it brings together things that many of
which are familiar to us but some of
which definitely aren't we live in a
society for example in which the idea
that religio was central to to the law
is supposed to be anathema right
we believe we think in the separation of
church and state that would have made
it would make no sense at all the Cicero
so so sometimes I think yeah if people
use the word you can try and figure out
what they're doing whether you can do
for sale on it but there isn't an
interesting thing to be done talking
about all the things we have called
religions and distinguishing them from
all the things we have refused to call
religions like Confucianism mostly
people have refused to call religion and
that's because one of the reasons that
is is because I really do think that the
driving question that generated a lot of
this literature is the one that
transversal it says straight which is
just whether they have instead of
Christianity and the answer is societies
are incredibly diverse in to the extent
that they have anything instead of
Christianity there's anything that does
whatever you think was GMT was doing in
19th century Britain France it's lots of
different sources in Chinese case is
very very difficult rallies have lots of
spirits right and they have ancestors
and all that it's just the fact kept
very separate from another set of things
that they also had whereas where I grew
up until very recently all that stuff
was definitely much of a part of a thing
and the thing wasn't religion it was
life well there was nothing every
morning you would go was a thing called
the Godfrey had side every house in the
Ahmadiyya everybody would go and you
would make it offering and you would
mention the high God and the earth
goddess and your ancestors and you would
ask for life and a good day if you said
to them oh you just had a religious
moment they'd say no and the ancestors
were they were there all along they
would they would they came out as it
were with me to the thing and and and
when I'm farming that's a religious
moment to I've got to have the right
relation to the earth goddess in order
to put my farms as it seems on so so
what's this distinction you'll make in
as I say there isn't a word
there's no good there is a word now but
it's you know it's the word produced by
a Christian missionaries looking around
so so I so sometimes my inclinations to
say there's no such thing as religion
there are all these really interesting
societies in which
which are packaged together lots and
lots of practices and beliefs and and
ethical ideas that packaged together
differently in different places I think
that some truth in Tyler's thought that
that the sort of the norms of everyday
life the norms of proper behavior
between people in the early societies
that he talks about are not very much
connected with the ritual stuff they
just they didn't think of them as
politically connected and in that sense
the rather odd sounding to ask thing
that he says which is primitive religion
doesn't have much to do with ethics it's
sort of true I mean there we were
discussing at lunchtime that there's an
exception here in ancient Judaism but
and I think that's true but the other
case is I think it's plausible to read
the evidence such as it is in the way
that he does so so sometimes I just
think I mean there are people who are
deeply interested in what we call
Hinduism though most of the people until
recently who did in division didn't
think they were doing intuitively they
could tell you what they thought they
were doing but they wouldn't have said
that people are deeply interested in
what we call in tourism
of course I'm naturally going to be
interested in especially if they're from
Europe or North America how to think
about the relationship between that and
you know what what various kinds of
Christians and Jews and Muslims do I
think that's a perfectly natural
question but it but we shouldn't assume
that religion is really a very
interesting kind and the point I was
trying to stress is that where the
explanation I wasn't endorsing any of
these explanations I begin by the
evolution that guys have no idea whether
there's good reason to believe them but
in those explanations religion doesn't
actually figure what figures is
complicated difficult rituals or and as
a reason for getting people to believe
you because it shows you're serious or
belief in invisible agency or so and
those explanations work perfectly well
without talking about religion and
indeed they might work better if you
thought of if instead of pulling out
the things that look to our flight
religion you thought about these earlier
phases of society and all their
complexity including all the social
structure and so on and thought about
that as what you were trying to explain
bringing in belief in spirits or ritual
or whatever at various points but
focusing on the question how did human
societies get to be complicated so it's
not but um so the key point I suppose is
sort of the most abstract point is that
is that religion Weber was right we
shouldn't be interested in the essence
of religion that's not that there isn't
such a thing and there isn't one for two
reasons actually one reason is the one I
just gave about the fact that these
societies have put together different
complex packages the other is a thing
that they both they all got right the
current form of any religion like the
common form of anything of any social
thing it's best understood by seeing how
it got to be that way at least one of
the ways of understanding it is a hard
historical explanation of how the
elements are put together when Weber is
trying to explain the Protestant ethic
he takes us through historical
narratives about how the elements of the
Westminster Confession what that would
do to your mind is it were to believe
that what it did do and how that led
people to adopt a certain form of life
many contemporary people don't think
it's the right explanation but that
isn't the point here the point is that
it's an explanation of the right shape
and therefore inconsistent with
essentialism about about that what
explains the connection of between
simples activities and Luther's
activities isn't an essence in the
shared essence of the two activities
okay so could you contrast the view that
there's no essence of religion with a
view which ice that there is in essence
of law so a lot of the things you said
seems to apply the law but as you raise
your hand I thought I'm going to have to
tell him that this is true that law as
well if you could yet
I mean look again inside since I don't
need to say anything well look just you
know the question when Matt Gutman
Luke's Minh goes the Barack's will he
call Bharat Zealand to study peroxy
jurisprudence what's this course and
this question is whether they have
instead of law what do they have where
we have law and you right he's a good
observer so he notices that what they
have isn't pretty like what we have but
he calls it though anyway because that's
the best word for it and I mean the
closest word for it now that that's I
think the thing that's inevitable as I
said because of the task of fresh when
you're trying to make sense of
unfamiliar practices what can you accept
make draw attention to connections with
familiar branches what else would you do
so I don't mean that I'm not sort of
correcting him I'm just saying that you
know once you get into it what what you
should probably say is all I have some
stuff that's said like this but he hit a
legal system you know a lot of the
descriptions of African pre-colonial law
were written for the purpose of colonial
administration and as you know the
British theory of colonial
administration by the early 20th century
was that you should engage in what they
called indirect rule you should try to
govern people through the
institutions the district commissioner
would stand behind the ME air or the
Sultan or the king or the chief but the
chief would manage things and as long as
what he did was roughly consistent with
the interests of the Empire which were
not very broad I mean they weren't
hidden a lot you'd let him do it then
gradually the colonial officer starts
writing down what he fears being decided
in these cases and that gets turned into
customary law that's what that's what
customers are it is well it's what was
decided early on by Cyclone
administrators but they were trying to
interpret the local thing they weren't
trying to make something up they were
trying to interpret the local thing of
course what's produced as filial law in
that context is going to be very very
baqia because if you think about the
incentives for locals who understand
what's going on they are to tell
whatever story will currently suit the
interests of the class that he's
listening to and one of the things that
happens in Africa in that process for
example is that in places where women
had a good deal more of social Authority
in the past people who came from a place
where with the exception of Her Majesty
the Queen Victoria women did not have a
lot of social Authority they asked men
what the rules were why would you ask
women and the result was they got as it
were an Andrew sent version of what have
been going on before and later
anthropologists have tried to undo that
they've tried to reconstruct I don't
mean that all these places were of
course sexy especially Arkell and all
that but my ancestors certainly were but
they were nevertheless women had an
enormous amount of social power in 19th
century Society for example so so I want
to say you know if you think that that's
the question what do we have what do
they have instead of what we have then
then it's natural that is a family
result Flint's concept is natural well
over here you have something which we
recognize as law because it's a little
bit like this feature of our lore and
over here we have something that we read
because there's a little bit like this
feature of our little and so on you know
you can think about this I mean we have
a paradigm of this sort of difficulty I
think in in the fact that you know the
first stage of comparative law in the
United States is comparing the brick the
British Constitution and the American
Constitution well the American
Constitution is a determinate thing we
can have a copy of it Briscoe solution
is not in that sense of the terminal
thing you cannot have a copy of it who
could read to know or Brice or somebody
going on for volume after volume about
what the British constitution is so so
does Britain have a constitution will
they use the word to describe something
but what they're describing is
significantly enough different from what
after the French and American
revolutions we mean by a constitution
this we should probably not assume that
we know really what's going on when we
call them both constitutions but we
should be very careful not to assume too
much I think so yeah you know all the
big things live in law culture there's
no word for culture in my father's
language either doesn't mean we don't
have one it's that we don't think about
the world in that way and we do now I do
want to know what the Asante world for
culture is gorgeou for one last question
I'm wondering the contemporary
evolutionary sort of explanations of
religious belief
don't make reference to evidence power
of explanation and of course some of the
so-called religious believers may not
understand themselves to be responding
dividends in that way but I assume that
many are and I'm wondering if just the
fact that that doesn't feature in the
explanation there's a possible source of
explanation itself could be seen as a
kind of disrespect and non-neutral or in
some sense non cosmopolitan way of
explaining religious practice and
religious identity so I think that if
you want to make sense of what we call
religions in many places in any place
where we call anything religion I think
the first thing you need to do is to try
and see how it looks
from the point of view of the of the
practitioners and this is something that
I think Tyler is good at Tyler's as I
said Tyler's basic view is that these
that the initial structure of religion
the belief in invisible agency is a
perfectly natural way to respond to the
world not because the spirits are there
but because you use to think about
things the models you have and human
beings have you know have evolved to
have pretty complex ways of
understanding other human beings that's
why society is possible and they are
very using them as rewards using that
way of thinking is in theory of mind and
so he thinks it's completely
unsurprising that when you're trying to
make sense of something the first type
ah versus you cry is well it's it's like
you know me it has beliefs and desires
and feelings but he didn't like me in
not being embodied in a body roughly the
shape so I'd say that tell I mean even
the Tyler is the one who uses the
primitive and savage
quite often he does actually basically
assume that this is a reasonable
interpretive way of interpreting the
world and the tellurium in anthropology
people like Evans pictured in the mid
twentieth century and Robin Horton who
writes about Nigeria in the later 20th
century they all start from that they
all start from the idea that what we're
trying to do is to see why equipped to
these concepts the world makes sense not
but it not that it it's not that they
believe it it's that they see that it
makes sense they do it the courtesy of
making it intelligible the courtesy of
sustained so so I think and I do think
that that is the beginning task and it's
a sort of prepare Ettore task before you
can ask the other questions about how it
came to be this way and so on
and I do think that some that there's a
great divide among people to think about
religion today but some of the evolution
psychologists are you know there sit
like Richard Dawkins they are not very
respectful of realist ideas and I think
that that means they usually inquire
often misunderstand what's going on they
make criticisms that seem to the
contemporary believers uncomprehending
and and you're not going to make it if
the object of the exercise of Dawkins
exercises that swayed people to give
stuff up
you better get what they're believing
right before you before you try and to
get that wrong not only do you need to
get it right but you need to address
them respectfully which is a separate
thing from getting it right and if you
don't do either of those things
you've got no conversation
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]